The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we're going to
dive into Cost, Price, Markets,
and Support Mechanisms.
The support mechanisms
otherwise known as subsidies.
So this is Lecture 18.
We're approaching the end
of our course, actually.
We have about, we have a
handful of lectures left,
and then we go
our separate ways.
This particular lecture will be
followed up not this Thursday
but the following Thursday.
We'll have a guest
speaker come in
and talk about the
cost model that he's
developed for PV into a
very high level of detail,
so it'll be a lot of fun.
And you'll be able
to use that cost
model to model your own
PV devices, apparatus,
and so forth.
Next Tuesday, a week from today,
we'll be touring a PV facility.
It'll be here on campus to
make it easy for everybody.
We'll go over to
the student center
and tour the PV system up on the
roof there, as well the balance
of system components.
So we'll be able
to have a close-up
look at how that works.
But today, cost, price,
markets, and subsidies.
We want to talk
about those items
because, at the
end of the day, PV
is a product that is competing
against bulk electricity.
And if we can't compete
against the bulk electricity,
then our on-grid applications
are going to be rather limited.
So we want to understand how all
this works and fits together.
I'll be providing you several
snapshots and several pieces
of the puzzle with a lot of
discussion back and forth
over the course of
today's lecture.
First off, let's dive
into PV cost and price.
What is the difference
between cost and price?
They're used interchangeably
in colloquial language,
but there's a big difference.
Jessica?
AUDIENCE: Cost might be what
it costs the manufacturer,
and price is what it's
sold at [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So cost is what it actually
costs to make, to manufacture,
and price is what people
are willing to pay for it,
what the market is demanding.
So sometimes price can be
above costs-- you're hopefully
in that situation most of the
time-- and sometimes price
can actually be low cost.
What is an example of when
price could be below cost?
AUDIENCE: The Amazon Kindle?
PROFESSOR: The Amazon Kindle?
Why would it be doing that?
AUDIENCE: Because they want
get people to adopt the device
and then make money on
subscriptions to books
or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Hm.
A loss leader, right?
Something like, for example,
if you buy your razor handle,
and that's really cheap, but
then they gouge you on blades.
Or other examples
include the cheap items
in the front of a store.
You walk inside the
store, and then you're
barraged by all the more
expensive ones right inside.
So loss leading can be one
example of price below cost.
Another?
Other examples?
What if I start
making a gizmo, and I
pocket an enormous profit.
And all of you start watching
me make that gizmo and say, hey,
I can do that.
It's pretty simple.
It doesn't take a
rocket scientist
to manufacturer that gizmo.
I can do it too.
And everybody starts
manufacturing gizmos.
Pretty soon, we overwhelm the
demand, at least at that given
price point, and the
price is depressed
as we enter a price war.
We enter what is called
an oversupply condition.
That's another example where
price can fall below cost.
And another reason
why price can fall
below cost is simply
the price, or the market
you're trying to address,
simply won't buy your product
at that cost.
And that's the case with
substitution economics.
If we're competing against
fossil fuel-based electricity,
let's say, and we want
to compete against that,
we might not be
able to manufacture
solar panels cheap enough
to address certain markets.
For example, Wyoming, which
has $0.05 per kilowatt hour
electricity due to
cheap fossil fuel.
The southeast of
the United States
as well, where the TVA, the
Tennessee Valley Authority,
has very low-priced
nuclear and coal power.
So these are examples of where
price might be below cost.
We're going to get more into
that over the course of today's
lecture, because
there are some very
interesting geopolitical
debates occurring right now.
Oftentimes the two sides are
very staunch in their positions
and there isn't much nuance,
there isn't much shade of gray,
there aren't many rational
arguments presented.
And instead, we're going to
be diving into some of that,
discussing the nuance
over today's lecture.
Let's dive into cost first up.
This is a paper that I
presented already in class.
I've also steered some of
the project groups toward it.
This is a proceeding
back in-- whoa.
This wasn't 2009.
My apologies.
This is 2003.
This was presented at
the 3rd World Conference
of Photovoltaic Energy
Conversion by Tom Surek,
presenting a very
simple cost model,
if you will, for PV, more
specifically the impact
of efficiency on cost.
And by no means was
this the first time
that something like this
had ever been presented,
but it was a nice
summary of the work
to date, highlighting
several, I would say,
key levers, cost levers.
Efficiency-- that's the
solar conversion efficiency.
Processing costs-- that's
the materials and processing
costs for the module in
dollars per meter squared.
The manufacturing
yield-- that means out
of, say, 100 cells into
your manufacturing line,
how many make it through
to the other side
without breaking
or being discarded
due to manufacturing defects?
Capital equipment cost-- that's
depreciated over several years,
meaning you buy
equipment up front,
but then due to
financial gimmicks,
you're allowed to
allow that cost
to hit your books over an
extended period of time,
not all at once upfront.
Overhead, and so forth--
overhead being the health
insurance, if it is
paid to the workers,
and, of course, R&D
and the CEO's salary,
and so forth could be lumped in.
So this is a very simple
way of estimating cost.
It's a linear equation,
a direct relationship.
What is, I would
say, the economics,
or a more sophisticated
way of looking at cost?
Other than just saying it's
the dollars per watt-peak,
you would look at it in terms
of cents per kilowatt hour.
Right?
You would look at
it in terms of,
how much do you pay for
your electricity coming out
of the wall?
Or in this case,
out of the panels?
What would factor
in to what is called
the levelized cost
of electricity,
when you're actually calculating
cents per kilowatt hour?
How would you convert
dollars per watt-peak-- OK, I
know how many dollars it
took to manufacture this.
I can also depreciate
my equipment costs
over several years
to manufacture this.
How would I go from dollars
per watt-peak into cents
per kilowatt hour?
We all agree that cents
per kilowatt hours
is the metric of
importance, right?
That's what we pay on
our electricity bills,
or at least some of us do.
So when we pay our
electricity bills,
we're paying in cents per
kilowatt hour from the grid.
And when we manufacture
our solar panels,
we pay in dollars per watt-peak.
Let's start simple.
Why is dollars per
watt-peak at all useful?
It's so far removed
from cents per kilowatt
hour that it almost seems
an artificial metric.
Why, again, do we use
dollars per watt-peak?
Jessie?
AUDIENCE: Because most
coal-based or most
fossil fuel-based electricity
is based on a capacity factor,
which is measured in kilowatts.
PROFESSOR: That's a good
way of looking at it.
And then the capacity factor of
solar would be based on what?
On the solar resource
locally, right?
And that might vary from
location to location.
OK.
So what dollars per
watt-peak allows you to do
is, given a rated nameplate
capacity, you can calculate,
based on the solar
resource locally,
how much energy will be produced
over a certain period of time.
And then from that, you
can calculate your cents
per kilowatt hour, because now
we're converting from power,
or rated nameplate power,
into energy, which we can use,
and which has economic value.
So there is a rationale, then,
for giving nameplate capacity
in terms of watt-peak.
In other words, rating a factory
in terms of megawatts per year
or gigawatts per year produced.
That means that each module
that goes on to the cell tester
is rated, and
there's an estimate
based on the cumulative
module production what
the total watt-peak output
of that factory was.
And then depending on where
those modules go in the world,
they might produce
different amounts of energy.
If you take those same
models and install them
in Alaska or
Arizona, you're going
to get widely varying
energy outputs.
OK.
So then, how do we transition?
We have the dollars
per watt-peak.
We have to know the local
solar insulation that
would allow us to calculate
what the cents per kilowatt hour
would be, assuming a
certain cost of capital.
We have to buy those
panels up front.
You have to buy from me a huge
number of panels, which are
going to last for 20, 25 years.
I'll guarantee it.
But you have to front
that money up front,
which means that you need to
lend that money from a bank
or from a financial
institution, and then you'll
be paying a certain amount
of interest every year.
And it's the spread, it's the
difference between the interest
payments and the money
saved that's going
to turn your profit.
And that's what's called
the rate of return
of your investment.
And there's also a payback
period, or a monetary payback
period, over which you're
not going to be making money
on average, but after the
payback period is finished,
then your solar array
will be a money press.
It'll be printing money.
And so over the entire
lifetime of the investment,
you can calculate an
average rate of return.
OK.
So given that setup,
we're going to be talking
about some incentive
mechanisms and, today, really,
really simple cost model.
More on Thursday
when we get back
to this, how we calculate cost
in a more sophisticated manner.
I want to introduce this
concept very simply at first,
just because there are
some parameters here
in the sensitivity analysis
that overwhelm all the others.
And they can be very simply
seen an equation like that right
up there.
And one of them is efficiency.
The processing costs
also matter quite a bit.
OK.
Inside of processing
costs, you also
have labor and
commodity materials.
And those can vary significantly
from region to region.
There are a number of
assessments out there.
I'm going to be leading us into
the current big debate which
has exploded in Washington
DC, the case of Solyndra,
and then SolarWorld filing the
complaint with the US Commerce
Department.
I'll be easing us into
this whole question
of US and foreign manufacturing,
using that more as a hook
to get us interested in the
overall topics of the day.
And then toward the
end, hopefully you'll
be able to see, with
more shades of gray,
what exactly is going
on and perhaps formulate
opinions of your own.
So where is PV cost actually at?
Where do the current cost
numbers currently stand?
It is extremely difficult
to get at true cost.
Price?
Price is easy.
You go out there,
probe the market,
see what people are
willing to sell panels at,
maybe send a few emails to
a few companies saying, hey,
I want to install
100 of your panels.
How much are you willing
to sell them to me?
This is what people do.
They probe the market.
They test it.
So price is fairly
easy to gauge.
But manufacturing cost?
If I go up to you
and say, hey, can you
tell me how much it costs
to manufacture panels
in your factory?
Would you be willing to
give me that information?
They'd probably say no.
Probably say no.
Definitely to me,
as a professor.
Maybe you as students,
they might show you
a little bit more of how it
actually works under the hood,
since many people believe
in the educational mission.
But, by and large, people are
fairly secretive about this,
because they realize that
their stock price is heavily
dependent on market perception.
And if I go out there and
write an article and say,
hey, your company
produces panels
at twice the cost
of yours, investors
are going to flee your company,
especially if it comes out
of a university like MIT.
And so there are big
repercussions associated
with the divulgation
of cost numbers,
and that's why it's very hard
to get to the bottom of it.
What you find most
often are aggregators.
These are consultancies that
work with several companies.
They may be, for example,
photon consulting
across the river in Boston.
It might be Greentech
Media consulting
branch, which is located here
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
There are many consulting
companies, and several of them
based here in the Boston area.
And these consulting
companies work with several PV
manufacturers and,
over time, begin
aggregating data and
presenting market trends,
generalized market trends.
A few of them single
out specific companies,
but most of them just
aggregate the data
and present general trends.
I presented to you this,
a few articles as of late.
These are relatively recent--
within the last three to four
years-- and because
there has been
so much change over the
last three to four years
within the PV market, even
an article three years ago
is highly outdated.
So you'll want information
that's within the last year
if you're going to be
using cost and price
information for your projects.
Even within the last few months.
And if any of you have
any doubts in that regard,
you can come talk to me.
So the fully loaded
module manufacturing cost
is shown here.
An estimate, again.
An aggregation based on access
to multiple companies' data.
Polysilicon-- this, of course,
being crystalline silicon
technology, which
accounts for about 85%
of the current market.
Polysilicon in blue,
depreciation in red.
What's depreciation?
AUDIENCE: Is that the
discounting of the capital
that we just talked about?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Exactly.
So what that means is,
I borrow a lot of money
to manufacture these panels,
to buy the equipment,
to buy the factory
and set everything up.
And then I have to pay
interest on my loans.
I have to pay interest on
the loans, and what I do is,
I start writing
off the equipment
as a loss to the company.
So that equipment is going to
be useful over a certain period
of time, and then we can
assume that it's outdated
and that I'll need to
buy the next generation
of manufacturing equipment.
So I can begin writing off
the value of that equipment
over a certain schedule, over
a certain period of years.
Five, seven, depending
on the company,
depending on the way they're--
I don't want to say cooking
their books, but the way
they're manipulating the numbers
in the accounting sector.
So the depreciation varies.
And it varies because the
interest rate at which you
acquire the loan,
and the interest
rate-- or the inflation rate
of the particular currency
in question, is different
in different regions.
So when you're
calculating depreciation
both of those things
matter, and that's
why those numbers can
vary from place to place.
Materials.
Materials cost.
These are the materials
used to manufacture
the module, typically
called commodity materials.
You would look at them as the
extruded aluminum components,
the glass in the front side,
the encapsulant materials,
and so forth.
All the fancy stuff that we
saw when we visited Fraunhofer
last week.
Let's see what else.
We have labor.
That's pretty
straightforward to see.
If we're manufacturing in China,
we are looking at a labor rate,
could be as low-- base
labor without adding housing
and so forth-- the base labor
rate could be as low as $2.75
an hour in US dollars.
And in US dollars in
the United States,
we could be looking at
labor rates of somewhere
in the range of $16
an hour before you
start adding in Social Security
and benefits and so forth.
And there may be
different levels
of automation in the two
different places, which
shifts costs from labor
into capital equipment.
So if you realize that you
have a much higher labor cost,
you might want to buy more
robots to do the manufacturing.
And vice versa, if you're
in China and you realize,
oh my goodness,
our labor rates are
increasing almost
exponentially, definitely
super linearly with time.
As the country
takes off and there
is inflation, wage
inflation, a company that
is trying to project forward
five or seven years might say,
well goodness, it
doesn't make sense for me
to flood my manufacturing
line with people
right now, because that
manufacturing line still has
to make a profit in five years.
And so I'm going to
buy more robots now.
Even though I might
not need it today,
I might need in five years.
And so there's a bit
of risk calculation
that gets thrown
into this as well.
Utilities and overhead.
That's pretty straightforward.
For looking at utilities, that
means the electricity, mostly,
to run the lines.
It could also be water which
is used in the manufacturing
process.
Note the caveats in
several of these studies,
especially the one out of
Lawrence Berkeley National
Laboratory.
Manufacturing cost, you can do
a number of things with that.
You can assume that you're
buying your polysilicon,
you're buying the polysilicon,
manufacturing cells, modules,
and systems.
Or you can assume that
you're buying the cells,
and the cells are commodity
products equal in price
throughout the world,
and that you're just
manufacturing the modules.
So you can cut costs
in many different ways,
depending on what
assumptions you make.
The price of the cell on
the international market
may be very different
than the cost
to manufacture that cell
in your particular country.
And cost is almost
one of those things
that you can torture
until it tells you
the story you want it to tell.
It's one of those
things where, if you
did these numbers a little
bit differently and said,
OK, we're buying cells and just
making modules, and then adding
shipment fees-- let's say
transport fees from China
to the United States-- China
and US might look almost equal.
Whereas if you integrate
over the entire supply chain
and say, OK, I'm going to be
manufacturing my polysilicon,
then my wafers, then my cells,
and finally the modules,
then you might start
seeing some disparity
based on these other
parameters shown here.
The point being, be careful
when you see a cost assessment.
Probe their base
assumptions and try
to understand what their
biases and motivations were
for presenting that
particular comparison.
Especially nowadays, where
you have more and more parties
with vested interests
in presenting
one story or another.
We'll get to that
in a few slides.
Experience learning curve.
Now we're getting into price.
We're venturing beyond
cost and into the regime
of price, which is definitely
more easily measurable.
And that's why we have some
fairly good data going back
several decades.
And you can see here,
this is cumulative sales
in gigawatt peak.
That means the cumulative
number of widgets,
in, this case, watt-peaks,
produced by solar industries
worldwide.
And this is a global average
module selling price.
Not the system, the module.
So not the balance of
system installation, labor,
and so forth, but just the
manufacturing of the module.
And what we can see
here is a general trend
over time with a
decreasing price.
That's good.
Sorry, decreasing
price with time.
That's excellent.
What is that called?
This curve here, plotted
in a log-log scale,
where you have a line through
the cumulative manufacturing
production versus price.
What is that curve called?
AUDIENCE: Is it an
experience learning curve?
PROFESSOR: It's an
experience learning curve.
And you'll get something similar
for any high-tech product--
computers, toasters-- as long
as the product isn't changing
significantly with time.
And even sometimes
if they are, as is
the case with the solar panel.
Solar panels back in the
1960s, or the 1970s, rather,
looked very different
than the solar panels
today in terms of the materials
and the processes used.
And it all falls along this
very interesting experience
learning curve.
So it's extremely
tempting to say, oh well,
what price do we need
to reach to be cost
competitive-- or
competitive, let's say,
with bulk electricity?
We need to reach a price of,
say, $0.50 per watt-peak?
Oh, easy.
We'll just project
forward and we'll
see how much cumulative
production is needed,
and then we'll
subsidize until we get
to that cumulative production.
And bingo, voila,
it'll happen by magic.
Well, the reality is that
each little bump here
along the learning curve was
some-- if you look closely,
you can kind of see
these little bumps here.
There were many traumatic
events within the industry
that forced people to innovate,
to produce better technology,
whether it's the technology
itself, something designed here
in the laboratory
at MIT or Harvard,
or whether it's something
innovated on the manufacturing
line where they
realized, oh, this
is a more efficient way of
manufacturing the solar panels.
It's cheaper.
This little bump
right here, boom.
This represents a period in
which prices actually went
back up year in and year out.
What could cause
prices to go up?
What are some of the
motivations for that?
I mean, scale's increasing.
The market's growing.
It's not shrinking at all.
It's not like the points went
back here as they went up.
So the market continued to
grow, the manufacturing capacity
continued to grow, but
the price went back up.
What could have caused that?
AUDIENCE: Demand
outpaces supply?
PROFESSOR: Demand
outpaces supply.
Exactly.
So in this specific
case, what happened
was the polysilicon
feedstock, which
is the input material
into this entire process,
was in short supply.
It takes about, in those days
it took about 24 to 36 months
to get a new plant online.
Long lead time and billions
of dollars of investment.
And so the polysilicon
suppliers didn't really
want to invest unless they knew
photovoltaics was for real.
And the PV industry
had exhausted
the elasticity of
the supply market
in the polysilicon business.
And polysilicon suppliers
looked at the situation
and said, well, let's let
prices go up a little bit.
It can't hurt us too bad.
We've been starved for
several years because
of low polysilicon
feedstock prices.
Let's let this increased
demand kind of push prices
up a little bit before we
really decide what to do.
And by the time
they decided what
to do, there was a lot of
them getting in the market
all at once, which
had this effect.
Boom.
Now, it's not only the
polysilicon, but also
the cell manufacturers,
the wafer manufacturers,
that expanded their capacity
during this time between 2007
and 2010.
Now today's most
recent price point,
as I saw it on one of our
more trusted websites,
put us down at around
$1.03, $1.05 per watt-peak.
So we're down here.
We're well below the
historical average trend.
We're in an oversupply
condition right now.
Why did the oversupply
condition come about?
Well, partly because of
this undersupply condition,
many people saw an
opportunity and said,
well, we can
address that demand.
We can grow in this
industry right here.
To grow in the industry,
you need capital.
You need access to
finances to expand.
What happened in 2008 in
Western countries-- and 2008
was more or less when it really
hit the fan, if you will,
in the United States
in particular.
What happened in
the capital markets?
AUDIENCE: Capital was severely
restricted becase we're not
providing a lot bones.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
We had the financial
crisis here in the US.
So in the United States, there
was a pull back of lending.
The government stepped
in shortly thereafter,
realizing that this was
going to be an issue.
There was the ARRA.
Does anybody know what that is?
It's not the American
Association of Retired People.
This is very different.
ARRA is the American Recovery
and Reinvestment Act, right?
This was the Stimulus Act.
And this act actually did
inject a lot of money,
or a lot of capital, into
renewable energy projects that
began hitting in
sometime between 2009,
let's say, at the
beginning, until 2011.
In this period right over here.
Anybody hear of
the word Solyndra?
Yeah?
You've heard about it?
Solyndra was one
of the companies
that received funding
under the ARRA, or "arra."
Under the Stimulus Act.
So a lot of
interesting things were
happening during this brief
little period right here.
During the mid 2000s, China
was getting a lot of bad rap
by environmental groups,
and the United States
as well, for its growing
greenhouse gas emissions.
There was a growing concern
over greenhouse gases
culminating in the
Copenhagen Discussions,
that countries, especially
developing countries,
had to do more to reduce their
greenhouse gas production.
And this, of course,
invited a wonderful tug
of war between a
developing country
bloc-- the most progressive
of the developing countries,
let's say, normally described
as BRICO, so Brazil, Russia,
India, China, and other,
including South Africa--
and the developed countries.
And you can see perspectives
from both, and it's wonderful.
The sophistication
of that debate
in terms of poli-sci arguments
was just beautiful to watch.
On one hand you had the
developing countries
that said, well, wait a second.
You folks in the
developed world,
you used a lot of fossil fuels.
And the majority of
the CO2 emissions
that have occurred to date
were from developed countries,
today.
So it's a bit unfair
that you're asking
us to reduce our CO2
intensity, because that might
hamper our own development.
Why don't you pay
reparations for the CO2
that you've already
emitted and help
us decrease our CO2 intensity?
So there were these beautiful
arguments being constructed
on both sides of the debate.
What China decided to do-- so
on the international spectrum,
not much happened.
And that's fairly-- sadly,
it's fairly typical of most
of today's-- I'd say the
larger the body happens to be,
whether it's the federal
government or the world
institutions, it seems that
things happen at a much slower
pace the larger the entity is.
But at a smaller entity, for
example, the state level, which
we'll see in a few slides,
in the United States,
a lot's happening right now.
And within China's
central government,
a lot happened in response
to some of that criticism.
They said well, there's a point.
More a point that
fossil fuel emissions
really decreases
our quality of life.
If you look at some of the
pollution in our cities,
that's not very becoming.
We can do better.
And furthermore,
we can create jobs
for the people who are
flooding our cities
from the countryside looking
for economic opportunity.
We can create new
jobs in this industry.
And we'll do it
by making capital
available to this new
nascent industry at a time
when it's very difficult to
achieve capital or acquire
capital in the West, in
Europe and the United States.
And so that's again happening
really in the mid 2000s.
And what we'll see
in a few slides
is the massive growth of
the Chinese manufacturing
market in response to the
availability of capital
in those countries.
Let me go back to a
slide that I presented,
I think it was lecture
number 1, where
we looked at the
cumulative production of PV
as a function of year.
And if we plot this on
the log-linear plot,
we can read the growth rate
off of the slope of that curve.
So this was somewhere around
10%, 40%, maybe upwards to 60%,
depending on what data points
you include in those lines.
Interestingly,
back in 1990, if we
look at the distribution
of different technologies,
multicrystalline silicon was
1/3, single-crystalline silicon
about 1/3, and thin-film
technology, namely,
pushed by amorphous
silicon, was about 1/3
of all manufacturing production.
As the market evolved--
sorry about this.
There we go.
So again, the
different technologies,
just to situate ourselves,
single-crystalline,
multicrystalline,
and thin films.
As the market evolved
going into the 2000s,
we saw this type
of breakdown occur.
We have silicon, or
crystalline silicon comprising
around 85% to 90% of the market,
and thin films not growing
as fast as crystalline silicon.
It was still growing.
The market overall
is going gangbusters,
but crystalline silicon
technology was going faster
than the others.
And in part, this
was due to the fact
that crystalline silicon
technology was a bit cheaper
than thin films at
the time, largely
driven by the
efficiency parameter
that we've just seen
in the previous slides.
And turnkey equipment
was available.
So if you had capital
someplace in the world,
anywhere in the world, and the
labor and commodities were such
that you could
compete in the market,
and the shipping costs weren't
extremely prohibitive to get
your product to the
most interesting markets
in the world, you could
compete because you
could buy turnkey equipment.
Even if you knew
nothing about how
to manufacture a solar
cell, knew nothing
about semiconductors
or solid-state physics,
what we've discussed
here in this class,
you could still go out and buy
a turnkey manufacturing line
and get technicians to
come in and teach you
how to manufacture solar cells.
That was the beauty of
these equipment companies.
And so the equipment
companies specialized
in crystalline
silicon technologies.
And as such, many
of the turnkey lines
that grew up out of
Greenfield factories,
especially in China, Taiwan, and
other places around the world,
leveraged these
turnkey manufacturers
to a great extent.
So price, markets,
and subsidies.
We're going to be
looking at-- it's
a bit of a hodgepodge
in the sense,
if we're addressing cost, price,
and manufacturing all together
in one big stew, I
think that's useful
because the three
are interrelated.
A price is difficult
to set without a cost,
and the manufacturing
is part of that story
and can help us tease
apart what exactly
is going on right now with
Solyndra, with SolarWorld,
and so forth.
OK.
So let's start with
customer needs.
Just to acquaint ourselves,
if we're talking about price,
we can't divorce price
from our customer.
And in terms of what
our customer needs are,
we have on-grid applications.
That's represented
by, for example,
a solar system on my house,
on the student center.
These are systems that
are tied to the grid
and using the grid as a battery
to store the excess energy.
Off-grid, this represents, for
example, the Lighting Africa
project here within our class.
These are folks who don't have
access to an electrical grid
and who need to have
that electricity there.
So while people on
the grid are worried
about cents per kilowatt
hour, people off the grid
might be worried about the
dollars per hour of light.
That might be their
metric of merit.
So from the customer's
perspective,
what is their value?
What do they get from the
solar PV system on the roof?
These parameters under
here, underneath each
of the pictures, represent
the value parameter.
And again, it's a
very cartoonish way
of thinking about it.
It's a lot more complex when
you start getting into the weeds
and figure out what the
customer actually wants.
Reliability factors in,
access to the product, repair,
reliability, and so
forth, factor in as well.
There are many factors
that add in to value.
But what we've done
here is emphasize
the biggest levers,
if you will, and some
of the biggest differences
between different applications
of PV.
If you're looking at the solar
panels on top of the Toyota
Prius, you might not
really care about the cents
per kilowatt hour,
because you're
paying $20,000 for your car, so
what's a few extra dollars here
or there?
But you might care
about the watts
per meter squared, which is
really an efficiency parameter.
You might want it to
satisfy a certain function
that it could not do
otherwise if the panel was
too low efficiency.
If you're sending something
into outer space, again,
you might not care about
the manufacturing cost
of the panel, , because the
shipment costs, in other words,
putting it onto the rocket and
sending it up in outer space,
is $10,000 per kilogram.
You might be more worried
about, how much does it weigh?
What is the specific
power of the solar panels?
Likewise, if you're installing
them in a big-box company,
for example at Walmart
or Kmart, and you
have a big flat roof
that isn't very strong,
isn't well reinforced, you
might care about that parameter
as well, or the grams
per meter squared.
I'm sure that
factors in somewhere.
Actually, it doesn't.
So there are many
other parameters
that could matter for a
particular application.
Dollars per meter squared
for aesthetics for a building
integrated system.
I've had architects
come to me and say,
can you make a
yellow solar panel?
I'd really like a
yellow solar panel.
And here I am thinking
of the solar spectrum
and seeing the biggest, the
peak of the solar spectrum being
reflected away from the panel
into the observer's eye,
and I'm thinking, well, I can
make it kind of dark yellow,
yellowish.
OK.
How much are you willing to pay?
And there are many different
parameters here that matter
for the customer.
This one right here is
a concentrator system,
so you have these optics
that concentrate the light
into a small little
spot, and they're
looking at the watts
per millimeter squared.
A very small device, how
much power does it output?
The cost of the actual
device is almost irrelevant.
It's the power
output that matters,
because the majority of the cost
is sunk in all the commodity
materials around it.
All right.
So we're getting into
this because we're
going to focus largely
on on-grid applications,
and I'm going to
explain to you why.
If you're in the
Lighting Africa project,
you probably care
mostly about that.
But the on-grid
applications currently
comprise 95% of
the current market.
Substitution economics.
We're substituting
PV with, or we're
substituting fossil
fuel-based power,
on average in the United States,
somewhere around 600 grams
of CO2 per kilowatt hour.
We're substituting
that with PV which
is on the order of a
factor of 5 to 20 lower.
So what types of grid
electricity will PV substitute?
What does this mean for
traditional generation
companies, also called gencos?
And what is a fair selling
price for PV electricity?
Very interesting questions.
So in terms of
markets, this is just
a breakdown of off-grid consumer
applications and on-grid.
When I first got into this,
somewhere around here,
it was broken down about
50-50, PV on-grid and off-grid.
Today, much further down,
off-grid applications, probably
below 10%.
I don't know the
precise numbers for you,
but it's stayed relatively
flat compared to the growth
rate of the on-grid.
And the reasons for this, we'll
see in a couple of slides.
This is the value of PV
electricity, per a 2008 report.
If you look at what is easily
monetized-- easily monetized
depending on the policy
in a particular case--
you have the cost of
fuel, the cost of capital,
typically for a power plant,
the CO2 emissions offset.
This is if you have
a price of carbon.
Notice how small it actually
is, leading a lot of people
to conclude that maybe carbon
pricing isn't the biggest lever
for bringing PV onto the grid.
That's a whole other discussion.
We can have that later.
Grid losses.
These are the transmission
and distribution losses,
the difference between having
the PV mounted or distributed,
the power generation
source mounted right
on the site of use, as opposed
to a centralized location that
has to distribute it.
These are much more
difficult to monetize.
And you can add in here health
impacts related to emissions,
and so forth.
You're looking at the
security, the reduced
risk of having a product
producing electricity
at a certain known
price for 20 years.
You're also looking
at tax bonuses.
These are tricky because
tax policy can change.
You're looking at uncertainty
in your raw feedstock
material, the fuel.
And the need for
backup is something
that reduces the value
of PV electricity.
If you, at some
point in the future,
will need to back up PV
power with something that
is more dispatchable
and it's still
an uncertainty in
the power grid,
that's something that
is reducing the value
of installing the PV today.
Some might argue that that
$0.01 negative is actually
a drastic underestimation
of the risk associated
with backup power needs.
But this is a fair look at
what the so-called true value
of PV electricity
might be, which
would lead us into pricing.
If we know the value,
we can enter pricing.
And not many people can
argue with this, because this
is substitution economics.
This is just
saying, OK, how much
does it cost to produce
fossil fuel electricity?
And let's substitute that.
Anything over here in the yellow
is what people might say, well
gee, if we really look at the
true price, or the true cost
of fossil fuels, this
is what it really
costs if we take away
all of the subsidies
and add in all of
the externalities.
What's an externality?
What's an externality mean?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it
when the consumer
isn't aware of something that
the [INAUDIBLE] is doing?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So when the consumer--
or let's put it this way.
When the true
impact, price impact,
is not factored into
the selling price.
Let's say-- hm.
Let's say that I sell
you a miracle drug.
And it allows you to be
5 times more productive
than you are right now.
But then every time
you have your needs,
down the toilet goes
a bunch of chemicals
that the water plant
now needs to filter out,
and the water plant
begins failing
some of its standard tests when
they measure water quality.
So they add in some more
filters into their system.
They figure out how to
get rid of this compound.
And now all of the water
treatment facilities
around the country begin
adding in these new filters,
and it costs somewhere on
the order of $1 billion.
That is an externality.
That's something
that wasn't factored
into the price of selling
you that miracle drug that
allowed you to be 5
times more productive.
It's an example of
how everybody pays
for the acts or the
purchases of a few.
And that's the case with
energy production as well.
So it's difficult to
argue in economic terms--
or it's difficult to
put a specific price
on externalities, because
these could be things
like premature deaths.
And there are statisticians
who will calculate
the number of people
who die prematurely
as a result of exposure
to mercury or cadmium
or some other
emission coming off
of a fossil fuel-burning plant.
But then how do
you monetize that?
You have to assign a
value to a human life
and say that a certain economic
value was lost, both in terms
of productivity cost,
but also in terms
of the investment due
to that person dying.
And they do that.
In government, there is
a value to a human life,
and it can vary somewhat
from one group to another.
But it's very difficult
to price in externalities.
And that's why oftentimes
these things in yellow
here are neglected
or not considered.
For the purposes of
today's discussion,
we're just going to factor
in mostly these parameters
right here because we have
a greater hold on them.
So in terms of PV
installations worldwide
cumulative, I want to
compare and contrast
where our customers are versus
where our manufacturing is.
And we'll get to some
really interesting questions
associated with that.
So look at that.
Where would you expect
PV to be installed?
You'd expect it to be installed
in the sunniest places.
Why?
Because the amount
of energy produced
is related, proportional, to
the amount of solar resource
that's available in that spot.
But from a customer's
point of view,
solar resource isn't everything.
They're also looking at
the cost of displacement.
What is the price of
electricity I'm paying?
And how much of
that can I displace
with my PV electricity?
So there's some more
sophisticated concern here.
And further, the
price of electricity
might not only be dictated by
the true cost of production
of the fossil fuel power plants.
There may be a few
governments out there
that say, well, look at
all these externalities.
We want to begin
factoring those in.
We want to provide an
incentive for people
to produce PV electricity.
That's commonly referred
to as a subsidy.
So if we look at the
total installation,
EU is really leading
the charge here.
And we saw on those
installation maps,
there's not a heck of a
lot of sun there in the EU.
Germany has a solar radiance
similar to what we have here
in the northeast of the country.
And we know that most of the PV
installed in the United States
is going into the southwest.
Japan, rest of world, USA,
a relatively small fraction
up there in China.
Tiny, tiny little bleep.
China's the peach one
right up there at the top.
So I would say less than 5%
of total installed worldwide.
Actually this is 1.5%.
You can read it off
right here, the division.
OK.
So we have a very
interesting perspective
here about our customers.
This is a breakdown, again,
in terms of customers again.
A little bit better detail.
Instead of just seeing EU,
we're looking at a variety
of different customers.
And this is new
installations worldwide.
So if, for example,
this blue bar goes down,
it just means we installed
less PV this year
than we did last year.
It doesn't mean that the total
amount on the grid went down.
It's just new PV installs.
So the blue down
here is now Germany.
We have these countries that
are like flashes in the pan.
Italy, for example--
sorry, Spain.
This one, Spain, grew up really
quick and then disappeared.
Italy grew up really quick
and then is shrinking.
If we extended out to
2011, it would be back
to a very small amount.
We have USA that's
consistently growing.
That's a nice healthy market.
In Germany, that's
growing as well.
Wow.
What an interesting dynamic.
Why did Spain have
this flash in the pan
and then shrink suddenly?
What did they do differently
than Germany did?
We'll start asking
those questions
and answering them
in a few slides.
If you really want to
get detailed information
about the US, where PV is
installed in the United
States, one of
your MIT colleagues
and a bunch of NREL folks
got together and put up
this beautiful archive, if
you will, compendex of as many
PV installations
as they possibly
could in the United States.
So that's the website.
Unfortunately, I didn't
include it in your slides,
so you might want to
write that down if you're
curious about it.
Wonderful resource.
Again, NREL, National
Renewable Energy Laboratory
based in Golden, Colorado.
And you can see the
install distribution
throughout the United States.
Again, a bias toward states that
have high electricity prices,
like New York and Massachusetts,
and lots of sun, like Arizona.
The price of electricity
is rather low in Arizona.
It's below $0.10
per kilowatt hour,
but the amount of sun
available is very high.
Whereas California has both.
OK.
So we talked about the customer.
Now here we're talking
about the manufacturers.
So we have the
customers, the demand;
the manufacturers, the supply.
Obviously, the manufacturers
are growing at the same rate
as our customers are installing.
Even faster, mind you.
Inventory rates are almost,
somewhere between 25% and 50%
nowadays.
So the production has grown
faster than the demand has,
at least at current prices.
What we've done right here,
or what is done right here
is a normalization
by market share,
just to demonstrate how
the market dynamics are
changing as the industry grows.
So from 2005 to 2009,
this doesn't mean
that the industry stayed flat.
It continued growing
at a breakneck pace,
but the countries which
comprise the manufacturers
have changed significantly.
So let's look at
Europe first off.
Europe pretty much
started really feeling it
during the financial crisis.
They couldn't keep
expanding in 2008,
and then when prices really
started to drop, 2009,
as we saw, they didn't
continue expanding.
Were a bit uncompetitive.
US, shown here in the
green, again, dropping.
India, I guess sort
of growing now.
It's definitely on the upswing.
Japan decreased
considerably, considerably.
During the 1990s
and the early 2000s,
Japan had the largest solar
company in the world, Sharp,
better known for
microelectronics
that you might find
around your house.
Somehow, some way, the
executives at Sharp
saw this coming.
Saw a huge rise in demand coming
from Europe, and ramped up
capacity in Japan.
And when they did
that, they were
able to address large
portions of that.
They made a healthy
profit for several years,
and then they just
stopped expanding in PV.
Part of it might have been
they saw the market dynamics
changing.
They saw their costs,
their manufacturing costs,
relative to, for
example, China--
this is the orange right
here-- and Taiwan, above China,
above the orange-- and comprised
today-- this is 2009 numbers,
if we fast-forward
to today in 2011,
China and Taiwan comprise
55% to 60% of the PV industry
worldwide.
Production,
manufacturing, production.
So what does that mean?
Let's explore together some
of the interesting results
of that.
Let's look at some
of the good things.
What are some of the good
things about production going
to China and Taiwan
from, say, Europe
and the United States,
of solar panels?
Let's look at that for a second.
So we'll look at the glass
half full perspective.
What are some of
the good things?
AUDIENCE: It's more likely
that these developing countries
will use solar panels?
PROFESSOR: More likely that
the developing countries
will use solar panels?
Was that the case over here?
Not really.
It's going.
OK.
I suppose, if the
technology's available there.
Maybe the technology isn't
quite cost competitive
with local electricity
yet, so there's
isn't that demand pull locally.
Maybe the realization
is that, well, goodness,
we can address this
European market.
They're willing to pay a
lot more for the panels
than we are, so we might
as well export right now.
But at some point
in the future we
might be able to
satisfy internal demand.
Yeah.
And there are gigawatt plants,
PV installs going up in China
right now.
In part due to increased
electricity demand, in part
due to weakened demand
elsewhere in the world,
and a very large
manufacturing base in China
that has to put their
panels out somewhere.
So there is, yes, adoption.
I'll cede that point.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Lower cost
to the consumer?
PROFESSOR: Lower cost
to the consumer, yeah.
So in the United States, if you
look at the price of installing
a PV system in
the United States,
the price of installing the
PV system is around $5.20
on your roof today.
The cost of buying the module
is around $1.03, $1.05,
from China.
And so that means that
80% of the profit margin
right now is being gobbled
up by a US company.
The price came down--
let's see, when
I installed the
panels on my roof,
I got a little bit
of a better deal.
But I would say the average
price for a PV system in 2007
must've been somewhere
around $8 per watt-peak.
And now the price is
down at around $5.20.
That said, in
Europe, in Germany,
which has 10 times more
installed PV than the US does,
the price of installing
a PV system on your roof
could be below 3
euros per watt-peak.
So the price is lower
because the profit
margin that the installers are
getting right now is smaller.
So yes, absolutely.
Lower cost product
in US markets.
That isn't the whole story
about what you're going to pay,
because there's still
the installer that's
stuck in between the Chinese
manufacturer of the module
and you serving as
the middle person.
Providing you value,
still, but still extracting
a very large profit right now,
a disproportionately large
profit, shall I say.
What are some of the
other good things.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If cost in
big markets is reduced,
then that could lead to
more market penetration,
and then the [INAUDIBLE] adopted
more, and even if prices go up,
it might maintain [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And so what you're
leading to here
is really what the demand
curve of PV looks like.
And in the past,
if you look at what
people are willing
to pay for PV,
let's say-- let's convert it
into dollars per watt-peak,
since that's the
universal unit of PV cost.
And this is the, let's
call it total market
size in terms of
watt-peak, and this being
a very, very large number.
What you can do
to-- first order.
Just how would we
construct the demand curve
for the United States for PV.
How would we go
about doing that?
How much are people willing
to pay for their PV modules
to offset the cost
of electricity?
Well, to do it right, we
need the levelized cost
of electricity analysis.
We'd assume we're borrowing
money from the bank
and do those fancy economics
that involve something
to the power of something, and
that being the interest rate,
and then we
calculate it through.
Just a first order.
Hand-wavy Mickey-Mousey.
We might take into consideration
the manufacturing cost
of the module.
Sorry.
Back up one step.
We might take into
consideration the cents
per kilowatt hour of the
electricity that we're
getting from the grid and the
insulation, the solar resource,
that is available at
that particular location.
So if we have data
granular to the state
level of the price
of electricity
on average throughout the
state, and the solar resource
availability on average
throughout the state,
we can immediately comprise
150 markets in the US.
Residential, commercial,
industrial for 50 states.
And then we'll have a demand
curve, a very simple one,
for how much people are
willing to pay for their PV
electricity.
And it looks more
or less like this,
if you start working it out.
Rough sketch.
This is Hawaii.
Those poor critters over
there, although they
have beautiful sun and
enjoy a wonderful life,
they're paying a lot
for their energy,
because they're on a
few rocks out there.
They have no natural
resource under the ground
to speak of, except
geothermal, I suppose.
But they're shipping
in a lot of their fuel.
That's why if you've ever gone
to Hawaii and rented a car,
you are surprised at
the sticker shock when
you go off to the gas
station and try to refuel.
Their price of electricity is
about $0.30 per kilowatt hour
residential.
But it's a very,
very tiny market.
So you're not going to be
able to satisfy much demand.
You're not going to be able to
produce too many panels there.
You start having
interesting things happen
when you start
hitting the bigger
markets, like the
tiers four and five
of California, Texas, New York.
These are big markets that
have a lot of people in them,
and they have larger
electricity prices
and/or large solar
resource available there.
And so at some point,
the demand curve
reaches these plateaus, where
if you decrease the price even
a little bit, of a sudden,
voom, the amount of market
you can address for
this amount of price
decrease, the amount of market
that you can address is huge.
And so the slope of this line,
the slope of the demand curve,
is indicative of what happens
when you reduce your price just
a little bit.
And so yes, producing
cheaper panels,
when you start hitting
these plateaus,
can result in massive, massive
demand pull, or market pull.
So that's another good
reason to have cheap panels.
Let's look at the flip side.
What would be some of
the downsides, let's say,
to module manufacturing
going into China?
You can assume anything
is on the table.
CO2 emissions, jobs, et cetera.
Let's start teasing into
some of those questions
and looking at some data.
I might flip back and forth
during the presentation
if we have to address
specific topics.
AUDIENCE: Bad politics
if American photovoltaic
manufacturers fail,
and it reflects poorly
on the industry and the
American political scene
and decreases support for that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So bad politics.
In DC, this is often referred to
as the optics of the situation.
How people observe, or how
people perceive something.
The litmus test
is not DC itself.
I was down there on
Thursday, and everybody
in the solar space was-- I think
it was Wednesday and Thursday,
yeah.
Everybody in solar
space was freaking out
about a particular event that
was going on in Capitol Hill.
I was telling
folks, don't worry.
It's not going to--
I mean, in terms
of the rest of the
country and the perception
of the rest of the country,
it won't be that significant.
And I'm sure Secretary Chu will
do a phenomenal job up there
in front of the
congressional panel.
He did phenomenal.
And so people were
really, really worried
about something that didn't have
too big of an effect outside.
Granted, what people
should be worried about
is the impact, for example,
that desequestration
of the discretionary
funds will have on R&D
once they start
kicking in in 2013.
If you mandate a reduced funding
level for funding agencies,
you will have an impact, and a
long-term one, for that matter.
So the optics of the situation.
There has been a slight
decrease in public support,
I believe on the
order of 5% to 10%
since the beginning of the
whole Solyndra affair, support
for solar renewables.
But the support
remains high, and still
continues to be high among
Republicans and Democrats
alike.
Especially when compared to,
say, congressional approval
ratings.
But let's not look down.
Let's compare
ourselves to higher.
What else?
What are some of the
potential negatives?
Let me start guiding
you, because you
hear so much about bad
this-- jobs, whatever.
Let me guide you into
some of the questions
you might not have thought of.
There is a colleague
of ours here
at MIT, Tim
Gutowski's group, that
is looking into matters
concerning manufacturing of PV
and installation of PV
from a CO2 perspective.
So if you manufacture your PV
in a coal-rich country that
is spewing out
emissions into the air,
you are going to have a greater
CO2 intensity per kilowatt hour
of energy that the panels will
produce over their lifetime
than if the panels
were produced,
say, in a country that has a
large abundance of hydropower
or geothermal.
Or, hey, even
produces solar panels
using other solar panels.
That'd be nice.
But in the growth situation
where solar is rising,
or the manufacturing capacity
is rising at 60% a year,
it's a little bit unfeasible
to think that solar will
power itself forward.
It almost violates one of
the laws of thermodynamics.
So we look at the
CO2 balance, right?
We think about,
gee, what if we were
to be smart about where we
manufacture and install PV?
Then it might make more
sense to manufacture PV,
say, in Norway, which
is based on hydropower,
and install them in China, which
is largely running on coal.
So from the CO2, from the global
carbon perspective, again,
these are externalities
that aren't being priced in.
OK?
CO2 and-- yeah.
Go ahead, please.
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't
they actually be
priced in Norway, because
they are in the new emissions
trading scene?
I mean, they're not
priced in China,
but the cost of electricity
in Norway doesn't [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So point conceded.
In certain countries,
some of the externalities
are factored in.
Not, perhaps, at the
levels they should be,
but some are factored in,
whereas in other countries,
they're not at all.
So we have what is
referred to in some terms
as an uneven playing field in
the sense that in some places
there are regulations
in place that
increase the price
of electricity,
whereas they aren't
present in other places.
And in some cases, they work to
your advantage, like in Norway,
for instance, or Switzerland.
Big hydro countries.
What are some other
potential disadvantages?
You hear a lot about jobs,
jobs moving overseas.
Let's start looking
at some of the numbers
next Thursday, when we
have Doug coming in here
and talking about
the cost model.
A good number to keep
in mind, a good number
to keep in mind for the
manufacturing of modules--
so back to this part right
over here-- for the module
itself, typical numbers would
be 2 to 12 people, depending
on what region of
the world you're
in, 2 to 12 people per megawatt.
So if you have a total market
of, say, 10 gigawatts--
it's larger than that.
We'll do quick math.
So if it's-- the megawatt would
be 20,000 people per gigawatt,
about 10 gigawatts, somewhere
in that range, on the low end.
And on the high end it would be
somewhere around 200,000 people
per gigawatt, on the high
end of the labor intensity.
So the high end of
the labor intensity
represents a company
like Trina Solar in China
that is extremely
labor intensive.
It's located in Changzhou.
It's on the high-speed rail
between Shanghai and Nanjing.
The low end of that scale would
be more representative of, say,
Suntech, which is almost next
door in Wuxi, which has adopted
a different approach,
saying, we're going to invest
in robots because we're
uncertain about where
the whole labor thing
is going to go in China,
where the prices
are going to go.
Or REC, which is a
Norwegian company,
but they opened a factory in
Singapore, which has very, very
low labor rates, because
they invested a lot of money
in capital equipment, in
robots to move modules
around their factories.
US, if you can look at
turnkey manufacturing lines,
are typically round 3,
3.5 people per megawatt.
Those are some good
numbers to keep in mind.
So when anybody comes to you
and says, jobs, solar jobs,
with these sorts of numbers
you can begin estimating, OK,
give me a number.
How big is the solar
market going to grow to?
What is the level of automation?
What is the labor intensity of
manufacturing of the modules?
And you can make an
estimate on the total number
of jobs, direct jobs,
direct jobs associated
with the module manufacturing.
Then there are all the
indirect jobs as well.
There are all the people
supplying the commodity
materials into your
manufacturing line.
There all the people
who are working
as administrative assistants
and R&D staff and so forth.
So it's not quite
as simple as that,
but it gives you a number
to really start grabbing.
And that, of course, doesn't
include all the installations,
installer jobs.
All right.
So we're talking about
grid-tied electricity.
I'd like to move on to
our next few topics here.
We're talking about
grid-tied electricity.
This is-- ooh, it's in German.
Sorry about that.
This is over a period-- "tag der
woche" means "day of the week."
And this is basically
the peak power
in gigawatts, instantaneous
at any given point.
So we have morning,
middle of the day,
night, middle of the day, night.
There's a little bump right
here during prime time TV.
And we have the output of PV
going from 5 gigawatt peak
to 30 gigawatt
peak, you can see,
beginning to eat into
the profits, essentially
the peak hours.
So let me differentiate
between base load and peak.
Base load power
would be voom, right?
Something providing a
constant power output
as a function of time, something
like a nuclear power plant,
coal fired power plant.
Peakers would be natural
gas fired power plants that
receive the call.
It's like, Jessica,
you're in charge
of the peaker over there.
Based on my weather
report today, I'm
going to need so many
gigawatts tomorrow
between the hours
of 10:00 and 12:00.
You think you can
turn yourself on then?
I'll pay this amount.
Yep.
Jessica's going to battle.
Yes, I can do that.
PV, on the other hand, is coming
on if the sun's coming on.
And to date, there isn't a
great degree of predictability.
We can see if that's
going to change,
based on one of our
class projects here.
But there wasn't a great
degree of predictability.
You can see here,
for example, and here
varying amounts of sunlight
from one day to the other
as a result of
changing insulation.
There's, of course, changing
demand as a day of the week
goes by.
On Saturday and Sunday there's
less demand for electricity.
So what PV is doing
is eating into some
of the highest-use
periods, which
is good from the market's
perspective-- from the, shall
we say, the "person in
charge of maintaining grid
stabilities" perspective,
because they want power
to be produced then.
They don't want to run out
of generation capacity.
And PV is avoiding
the situation,
or at least prolonging the
situation a few more years,
until we run out
of power generation
capacity on the grid.
As our population grows and
our energy intensity grows,
we're needing more
and more power,
but we're not building
new power plants
at that rate, generally, in
Germany and the United States.
And so PV is helping
to defray some
of that deferred investment
in new generation capacity.
So that's good.
On the bad side, somebody
who has invested--
let's say Mary's invested in a
natural gas generation plant.
She put the money down
for Jessica's plant.
Jessica's running it.
And now Mary realizes,
well goodness,
I thought I was going to
get a steady rate of return
over 20 years from my natural
gas fired power plant.
That rate of return was factored
into my economic analysis
when they borrowed money at
a certain rate from a bank,
and now you're telling me
that this upstart technology,
this new PV stuff,
is coming online
and is going to take
away some of my profit.
That doesn't work for me.
As a matter of fact, on
peak days in Bavaria,
which is the southeastern
part of Germany,
today PV can comprise as
much as 40% of electricity
on the grid during peak
hours during the summer.
And what that does sometimes is
force conventional electricity
producers to either turn off
or go into negative pricing,
meaning they shunt
the power to ground
so that they don't
have to pay to put
their electricity on the grid.
So that's an interesting
market dynamic
that's evolving as more and
more PV electricity enters
the grid in these regions of
high penetration, which include
California, Hawaii-- the
island of Lanai, I believe,
has up to 40% as
well on weekdays.
Bavaria in Germany, which is the
southeastern part of Germany.
Let me get to this
point right here.
Predicting where
the market will go,
we talked about the
demand curve for PV,
and we collapsed both
insulation and price
of electricity from the
grid into this dollars
per watt-peak figure, which
is how much people are
willing to pay.
We can also break it out into
annual solar energy yield.
This is the solar
resource available.
It's using the units of kilowatt
hours per kilowatt peak,
meaning the number
of kilowatt hours,
the amount of
energy, that a unit
of rated power, kilowatt
peak, of the solar panel
is going to produce.
So how much energy will a
unit of solar panel produce?
That's down here.
And of course,
larger amounts mean
more sun, more solar resource.
On the ordinate, we have average
power price of household.
This is US dollars.
It should be average
electricity price, US dollars
per kilowatt hour.
So that's how much people are
paying for the electricity,
what you're displacing.
And you can see that these
little bubbles here represent
the size of the market.
So as the price of PV
electricity comes down,
we are able to address
more and more markets.
As the subsidization of
PV electricity increases,
you move these little bubble up.
And as the subsidization
comes back down,
the market pull-- not the
manufacturing subsidies
but the use or
installation subsidies--
as they come back down, the
little bubbles move down,
and eventually rest at
their so-called true market
price without the
externalities factored in.
And so you can see
how we're beginning
to enter a regime where PV is
starting to look interesting
in a lot of places.
And as we begin
addressing these markets,
or hitting these markets, you
can imagine two Gaussian curves
intersecting, one being the
price of PV electricity,
the other being the price
of grid electricity,
as they intersect and overlap.
You expect an
exponential growth,
and that's what we're
seeing in the market today.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What is the
California [INAUDIBLE]
for tier 4 and tier 5?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So California decided
to implement more of a--
well, it is a little bit
regressive in that sense.
But what they did is,
they said let's, instead
of paying the same
price for electricity
for everybody--
which actually it
would be even the opposite way.
You know how residential, we
typically pay higher rates
than industrial?
That's because
industrial buys in bulk.
They buy electricity
Costco size.
We just buy it
corner-store size.
And so they pay less
for their electricity.
And California realized
this and said, well, this
is a perverse incentive.
What this does is it gives
an incentive to people
to use more electricity.
Because if you buy
in Costco size,
you pay less per
kilowatt hour than
if you buy in the corner store.
Instead, what we're going to
do is reverse that incentive
by penalizing the people
who buy more electricity,
so your rate is going to
be higher then if you just
bought a small amount.
So what they did is, the
government bureaucrats got
together with some of
the scholars and decided,
these are reasonable amounts for
a residential house to consume.
This is the next tier up,
this is the next tier up,
this is next tier up, and this
is completely unreasonable.
And so what they did is they
tiered their electricity.
And you have California
tiers 1, 2, and 3 represented
by the big bubble, and
tier 4 and tier 5 as
represented at higher pricing.
So if you happen to fall
into the tier 5 category,
you could be paying upward
of $0.30 per kilowatt hour
for your electricity.
And it's a way of penalizing
you for powering two swimming
pools in your backyard
along with, I don't know,
something in the range of
10 kilowatts of lighting
inside of your house.
Whereas, if you're running
on a meager budget,
you might do much better.
Do you have a
question over here?
AUDIENCE: Is it
only residential?
PROFESSOR: California's
tier 1, 2, 3, and 4, and 5?
That a great question.
Joe, would you happen to know
if commercial and industrial
fall into tiers as well, or
if it's just residential?
AUDIENCE: My guess would be no,
because that would be political
suicide.
PROFESSOR: Well,
even the residential
is political suicide.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The residential system is
actually kind of a bad one,
because if you have
like eight people
living in a house versus two, it
doesn't take that into account.
So it's not a per capita
thing. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So many
states and countries
have tried to adjust
incentive mechanisms.
And I'm not sure
specifically about
the commercial and industrial.
You might want to jot it
down and give a quick Google
search after.
Germany.
Growing gangbusters.
The market versus time.
This is installed capacity
annually versus year.
And again, subsidies, support
mechanisms, tax breaks,
incentives.
What we wanted to
emphasize here was
that Germany is not one of the
sunnier places in the world.
Look at this.
It's almost half of
the modulus installed,
and yet it has less insulation
than even here in the US
northeast.
Even the sunniest
places in Germany.
This is Bavaria.
This is the place that
hits 40% of electricity
on peak summer days
coming from PV.
And this is where we
are, right up there.
Same scale.
So something's going on in
Germany, and it's not sun.
The German government instituted
a number of-- this little D
represents
Deutschland, Germany--
implemented a number
of incentive programs
to increase the amount of
PV installed on the grid,
under the assumption that
if they had demand pull,
they would have a supply push.
Meaning, they would start
up local industries.
Initially it didn't quite take
off as fast as they hoped,
so they began providing
direct manufacturing support,
direct subsidies to install
PV manufacturing plants,
to the point where they
were willing to pay $0.50
on the euro for each piece of
capital equipment that moved
in on German soil to produce
plants in the mid 2000s.
So that combination
of events left them
with a booming market,
upwards of 100,000 jobs,
I believe, in Germany
related to PV manufacturing,
and a lot of PV
installed on their grid
as a result of the market pull.
So really, when it comes
to subsidies and support,
you have to decouple what
is market pull, which
means we want PV
installed on our grid
to offset our country's
carbon emissions,
versus manufacturing
push, which is to say,
you want to set up a
factory in my country?
Fine.
Come right in.
I'll provide you the finances.
I'll provide you a lower
cost of capital on your loan,
or help you by providing
a direct grant or loan.
And these are two different
support mechanisms,
and that's why you see that
dichotomy between Germany,
which installs a
lot of PV and has
a decent amount
of manufacturing;
the US, which has a
lot of installation
but not a whole lot of
manufacturing traditionally,
although it's changed,
the support has changed
over the last three
years; and China, which
has a heck of a lot
of manufacturing
but not a whole lot
of local demand.
It's because each country has
adopted a different approach
based on optimization
of different functions.
In terms of where a lot has
happened on the state level,
these are RPS, renewable
portfolio standard,
policies with solar and
distributed generation
provisions distributed
throughout the United States.
And you can see that the
states have picked up
where the federal government
lacked in terms of leadership.
In terms of getting
PV on the grid,
the states really pulled hard.
In, specifically, New Jersey--
some really oddball states,
like New Jersey here, installing
about 5 gigawatts of solar.
California had another more
of a market pull mechanism.
Rebate programs for
renewables, this
is if you install solar panels
you might get a few thousand
dollars back from
the state government.
And it just gives you a
sense of how the states have
filled in that void where
the federal government didn't
step in.
And this has come, in
part, to our detriment.
It's nice, because we can
allow-- the federalist
approach allows individual
states to say, hey,
we prioritize green jobs.
All right.
Let's support it.
Let's make it happen.
And that's certainly
Massachusetts' take.
California, Texas, certain
other states throughout the US,
including Mississippi
most recently.
But the downside
of that is that you
have each state doing its
own thing, each municipality,
each local electric utility
grid doing its own thing.
And what can happen
is diversification
of support mechanisms and
incentives to the point
now that if you want
to install panels
on your roof in the United
States, there over 18,000 ways
you could do it
within the US alone.
18,000 unique types
of paperwork that you
have to fill out,
depending on where
you are in the United States.
In Germany, you have
one unified paperwork
for the entire country,
and it's very short.
I believe it's two pages.
And in the United
States, you can fill out
a few reams of paper.
One of our friends
in California once
estimated it takes about $1
a watt to fill out paperwork
and to get certifications
and so forth.
Maybe it was a little
bit of an exaggeration,
but the price is high.
And so recently the
DOE has attempted
to address this as
well by fostering
a "race to the
top" type incentive
mechanism for states to
facilitate installation.
But still, in Massachusetts,
we had-- remember
for the system on my roof, we
had at least two inspectors
come by from different agencies.
That could have been
consolidated into one.
So while state
independence is good,
and local utility
independence is great,
from the perspective that the
federal government is lacking
in terms of moving
forward, the states
can push forward at
their comfortable speed.
On the downside, it makes it
very difficult for an installer
company to reduce
its costs because it
has to address a
multitude of local markets
throughout the US.
And that adds to cost.
In terms of projections,
I really hesitate.
Because in 2006, there were
a number projections of where
we'd be in 2010,
and many of them--
you can see the range here,
going from 4 gigawatts up to,
actually, I think Photon
Consulting had us close
to 30 gigawatts back in 2010.
Photon Consulting
was closer to right
than most of the other
groups, interestingly.
The 4 gigawatts was
obviously pretty far off.
So projections are very
dangerous because you
could be easily wrong.
This is just to
show you an example.
These are projections of
where the solar market is
going to go.
From the EPIA, which is the
European Photovoltaics Industry
Association, it's one
of the better sources
that I could find with the
various scenarios giving you
an indication, a tornado
plot, if you will,
of where the market is going
to head over the future.
And the bottom line
is that most likely
it will continue to grow.
Even though it's going to
enter a difficult year,
a difficult two years as
the oversupply condition
works itself out of
the market, we're
headed for some
pretty massive growth.
And just keep those
numbers in mind.
If this grows up to be, say,
a 100-gigawatt industry,
and there's two
people per megawatt,
that's 200,000
people employed just
in the manufacturing of modules.
Not counting all
the other people
on top of that, maybe
another order of magnitude,
if we use the car
industry as an example.
So we could be looking at
two million jobs worldwide.
And where they are, who works
on them, how the value chain is
distributed between
R&D, manufacturing,
this is all open.
The next decade
will decide that.
You'll help decide that.
So with that message,
I let you go.